la nuit descend sur la stèle pour le
match à caen propose être rasées
bienheureux
la raison comment allons nous coucher
le bail
éteignons la langue française encore une
journée je peux tu perds
qui vient faire là quel est ce moment j
ai mon choix fils bongo
ah bon ivanovic mac chocolatier toi toi
le fils de tomber pour amr chobaki plein
d'amour temps visite m'a complètement
kloet et rien n'a changé si on enlève
train-tram m l'usp a pris la langue fut
mèze et toi toi toujours reçu ça mais
toi à toi toujours aussi les dieux petit
que je te donne un grand coup de poing
deux wanna demain ce jour alors mon
horrible canaille est libre maintenant
quatre ans de balle mais je me suis
acheté à aa discale
teddy d'argueil je te reconnais bien là
avec sa délicatesse dans l'eau pour
montrer qu'ils incendient toujours
le puits de pétrole la flamme est plus
généreuse mais bientôt c'est ta mère
c'est l'enfer c'est ce qu'on appelle la
méthode mois on aurait donné le rôle de
la mère à jouer j'en aurais fait
davantage au retur ça passe trop
pression j'ai remarqué aucune subtilité
nechi c'est écoutez moi qui ne comprend
pas le russe comprendraient plus rien la
fenêtre à il ya quelque chose à piller
nos fils ne connais pas ton frère tombes
à char à igorre bien dorée de garde qui
s'en va inconscient au feuillet s'est
bien battu le jour tu ne cherches pas sa
bouche ce poste oui oui sa bouche 100%
ça bouge plus
moi je n'avais pas méconnu et la telma
gladu à vannes il est tjrs en kilos
coûts alimentaires
c'est fini c'est oublier qu'il ne
recommencera pas tout est vendu terim tu
sais mais j'y pense oui petit père du
père wenceslas mon petit papa marc laho
avec la bonne il n'a pas changé j'ai pu
le voir comment dyckmans va être de
revoir son fils du préfet rey fait tuer
juste beaucoup ce soir tu peux la voir
j'ai des pluies en même temps pour
restreindre aux élèves j'étais content
je serais lui n'a pas dit un mot
ils n'ont pas desserré les dents
peut-être qu'il ne m'aimait
un père cédera aux vallées jeter durci
les feuilles de tabac année ton père
était un si grand de fumeurs oui on fait
le salut militaire
ça changeait nord parfois ça y est donné
en bavardant bavarde qui n'était pas la
compter la dernière dernière histoire
cela où notre influence et la maintient
en sonja l'aplomb dallas du peu vrai je
viens faire qu'une bouchée qu'une
boucherie oui elle n'est pas vaccinée en
bout tu sues à dieu
j'ai pu sauver la vie de marc cambresy
la bouche le nez la bouche tu ne l'as
roma l'a manqué des continents v6
révolution et petites dont il n'a pas dû
le rester grandvaux pour la faire leur
révolution
après 7 et kato c'est gonflé pour un
soupirant demain j'irai faire brûler un
cierge
sheila bair azpeitia à je te reconnais
bien là brutal mais fleur bleue je te
pardonne aux cultures ball douce non je
ne suis pas rancunière voilà tout si
c'est ce que tu vas faire
on a les dents qui va les chercher une
casserole poudre à canon dans le cagibi
au fond de la cour mais on fait des
crêpes choses qui n'ont su score de
maincy d'image on fait d'abord et se
posent
tu n'es rien dans le noir c'est juste
paulhan cette boîte d'allumettes et
regarder de très près aux mouches je
saute il est terriblement vivant
toujours tête en l'air
allons nous coucher ce soir je ne
reviendra plus personne qui est moi